Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel released
a first look at Captain America 4 New World Order
featuring most of the major characters in a couple
super deep Cuts returning from The Incredible Hulk
movie a lot of Hulk characters in this movie we
also got a first look at Sam's new Captain America
suit he's gonna get a brand new suit during the
movie and some of the other villains as part of
the serpent Society because they'll be a big group
during the movie which is actually the payoff to a
joke that Kevin feige told heading into Captain
America Winter Soldier way back in the day
I understood that reference I know everybody's
looking for an Edward Norton Cameo seen now as
his version of the Hulk I'm not expecting him
to show up till Avengers 6 Secret Wars but we'll
break it all down I'll explain what's going on
we also learned why the movie is called Captain
America New World Order like what that New World
Order means if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos the
events of Captain America 4 will lead directly
into Thunderbolts that's meant to be the very end
of Marvel Phase 5 culminating with Val using the
weapons plus program to create the Sentry played
by Steven Yoon is now been confirmed that he is
playing the MCU Sentry the brand new scenes that
just posted are of a battle that Sam's Captain
America is getting ready to have with the serpent
Society while wearing his brand new super suit
everyone gets new suits in their movies Spider-Man
always gets new suits Iron Man even Steve Rogers
Captain America got new versions of the suit the
funny reason why they said they got rid of Sam's
cowl from the comics though is because they
said when they were making Falcon and Winter
Soldier the cow caused them all kinds of trouble
while filming they had to spend a bunch of money
to fix it and post so they just got rid of it
completely to make it easier for them to film
and the rest of his new suit it's just meant to
be a combination of Steve Rogers newest suit like
the darker suit from Avengers end game in his
previous comic book suit from Falcon and Winter
Soldier is still made of vibranium though like the
wings are still vibranium the characters here he's
getting ready to fight might seem familiar this
is Seth Rollins most of you know from the WWE I
believe he's playing Cobra or constrictor one
of the bigger members of the serpent Society
the woman that's with him is meant to be a version
of Diamondback as denoted by the diamond symbol on
her suit they've just changed her suit from the
comics she's fought Sam Wilson's Captain America
before they're building the serpent society as
like the obvious marketable main villains of the
movie but what's really going on is that Val
is supposed to be funding them using the CIA
to use them to obtain adamantium which has been
discovered on tmit's body the dead Celestial and
the Indian Ocean from the eternals movie so its
Val continuing to be super Shady working with
villains she kind of implied that during Falcon
and Winter Soldier We're not gonna need Captain
America things are going to get real weird real
fast meaning that she's gonna get super Shady real
fast it sounds like when things go sideways with
the serpent Society in this movie that'll clear
the path for her to create the Thunderbolts
the next scenes we have are actually from a
funeral that they're doing and a lot of people
are wondering whose funeral is this meant to be
because Falcon Captain America I mean they're just
calling him Captain America he's there in his full
formal military dress uniform with this other
woman also in formal military dress the rumor
is that she's playing his love interest in the
movie also from the military makes sense Torres
is also back from Falcon and Winter Soldier he's
still Captain America or Falcon however you want
to think about him his sidekick by the events
of this movie it'll be like the progression in
the comics when Anthony Mackey becomes Captain
America Torres becomes the new Falcon with a new
set of wings so like online there's just been a
lot of a lot of stuff about Steve actually some
people some people they think that he's in the
secret base on the moon here's the big thing
though they brought back Liv Tyler as Betty Ross
from way back in The Incredible Hulk movie like
she's finally back there have been rumors about
her coming back in Cameo at some point for a long
time now they haven't confirmed any kind of crazy
Multiverse Cameo scenes from Edward Norton as his
Bruce Banner Hulk but there are a lot of other
characters from that Incredible Hulk movie that
are back during this as you can see Betty Ross is
dressed in the customary black and U.S funerals if
you look around at the tombstones in the cemetery
where they're at at this funeral there aren't any
big Easter eggs on the Tombstone names but that
doesn't really mean anything necessarily Marvel
will probably alter those Tombstone names
in post-production just to avoid spoilers
but here's the thing this funeral they're at is
probably for Thunderbolt Ross himself there's a
new scene of him on set separate like a completely
different scene wearing a regular dress suit and
if he didn't realize they did recast Harrison
Ford as Thunderbolt Ross William Hurt passed
away recently originally it was going to be him
in the movie and the reason why they wanted to
recast him instead of using a completely different
character is because Thunderbolt Ross's character
was so critical to the plot that they're doing
the overarching plot for all of Marvel phase
fight like this whole dark rain era that they're
doing in the MCU because they wanted to turn
Thunderbolt Ross into Red Hulk during this movie
and they didn't want to completely pivot and just
turn Val into Red Hulk like they have other plans
for Val God damn it I want what's inside of him
Val's other alias in the comics is Madame Hydra
and she's critical to the villain storyline during
the movie though like there's a lot of shady
stuff going on in the background she's kind of
a villain in the same way that Sharon Carter is a
Villain Like characters that don't actually have
superpowers just work with technology or wield
enormous political influence so what I think
is actually going on in this funeral scene that
they're filming is that Valen Thunderbolt Ross are
pretending like Thunderbolt Ross dies during the
movie and using that as an excuse so the public
will stop thinking about him like it'll be a great
tragedy and they'll use it to their advantage but
they use this to fool all the heroes like Anthony
Mackey's Captain America as well so that everyone
thinks that he's dead stops worrying about him
and while that's happening Val uses the weapons
plus program in the leader character who's also
back from Incredible Hulk you notice he's green
now like he is in the comics you can see Tim
Blake Nelson getting ready for another scene here
his hands are painted green because they're just
doing the rest of the green for his body in motion
capture his larger head the visual effects so
he doesn't have to wear giant rubber head around
onset you also notice that his shade of green
will be a little bit different from the hulks
just to differentiate all the different characters
with gamma Powers Val is going to use him to turn
Thunderbolt Ross into the Red Hulk because his
whole thing Incredible Hulk was experimenting
with the Hulk's blood they even use She-Hulk to
tease Red Hulk and the reason why they weren't
worried about Harrison Ford being so old when they
recast him like he's played U.S presidents before
so obviously he's good for a role like that
but when it comes to all the action like the
big fight scenes you have to remember that he's
going to be motion capture Red Hulk for most of
the movie so they can do all the crazy Hulk vs
Red Hulk Red Hulk versus other characters like
Red Hulk versus Captain America fights and it's no
big deal the one person we haven't actually seen
on set yet is Mark ruffalo's regular Bruce Banner
Hulk and a lot of the plot is revolving around him
and he's been worried about this red Hulk type
of twist for a long time now he spoke about that
at length during She-Hulk like we have to destroy
all blood samples of us so that nobody can use our
powers for evil also by the event chance of the
movie Thunderbolt Ross is supposed to have become
U.S president I believe something's supposed to
happen to the previous U.S president during the
secret Invasion series because secret Invasion led
to dark reign in the comics that's what they're
using the secret Invasion series to set up in
the MCU I believe during the series something's
supposed to happen to that previous U.S president
like they find out that he's secretly a scroll or
he winds up dying or is assassinated in some way
according to Don Cheadle who we see Rhodey in all
the secret Invasion trailers by the events of
secret Invasion he's meant to be the right-hand
man advisor to that previous U.S president and
once something happens to that previous president
that paves the way for Thunderbolt Ross to become
president and they'll use him for like a Norman
Osborne style twist at the end of the comic book
secret Invasion where he winds up taking most of
the credit for getting rid of the bad Scrolls
everybody loves him but he's Thunderbolt Ross
so he uses that to gain more power by becoming
the US president and when that happens he just
opens the floodgates and lets Val do whatever she
wants to do all the Shady stuff that they normally
would think was too crazy to do all the stuff
that the previous U.S president wasn't willing
to do she's already become director of the CIA
by the events of black panther wakanda forever
she already wields enormous power it's just
that now she has carte blanche to do whatever
she wants here's when we get to the X-Men Easter
eggs weapons plus program the new MCU version of
Wolverine Val is also going to be running the new
weapons plus program and that's how she creates
the century by the events of the Thunderbolts
movie He's Just One of the next weapons plus like
Captain America or the Abomination during Captain
America new world order they're going to pay off
the dead Celestial from the eternals movie they
learn adamantium is discovered on TMS body and it
becomes a race by all the world governments
to try and claim it first if you don't know
the difference between adamantium and vibranium
the whole idea is that adamantium in the comics
was originally meant to be synthetic vibranium
scientists in the United States were trying to
replicate vibranium but they wound up accidentally
creating adamantium adamantium is just meant to be
unbreakable vibranium reflects Force that's why
it's so easy for Wolverine say to cloth through
vibranium it's kind of like a crazier version of
black panther using his vibranium claws to claw
Captain America's vibranium Shield like imagine
Wolverine slicing through Captain America's
shield so the new adamantium that they discover on
Tiamat is the key behind the new version of Weapon
X weapon 10 like he's just the 10th iteration of
the weapons plus program but I don't think they're
gonna debut a new MCU version of Wolverine till
well after Hugh Jackman comes back in the Deadpool
3 movie as his Wolverine entering Avengers 6
secret words so I still think it's going to be
several years before a new MCU Wolverine shows
up the next couple years we'll just see Easter
eggs for it like this adamantium showing up like
oh now they can create a new Wolverine they've
been talking about the main villain of the movie
being the leader character but they also say that
the serpent Society is supposed to be one of the
villain groups in the movie in the comics Val AKA
Madame Hydra is behind the serpent Society in
the serpent Squad like an evil team from the
serpent Society Sharon Carter is also supposed to
be working with the serpent Society in the movie
that was what teaser at the end of Falcon and
Winter Soldier was all about she was speaking
on the phone with the serpent Society characters
saying that they were just gonna pilfer the U.S
military stores now in the name New World Order
like the title of the movie Captain America New
World Order is a reference to the Winter Soldier
movie during that movie Arnhem Zola talks about
hydra's grand plan saying that their new world
order is about to begin purification process is
complete hydra's New World Order Hillary that's
what the movie titled Captain America New World
Order means the serpent Society was Sharon Carter
self Val Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk are basically
trying to take over create a new world order
so the movie will have a very Winter Soldier
type of vibe with all this crazy red Hulk stuff
going on in this adamantium stuff we'll start
getting more footage for the movie soon so of
course I'll do more videos and I'm working on a
Loki season 2 trailer video that should post the
next couple of days be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my breakdown of the new Deadpool 3 title
in Easter eggs the Loki series and click here
for my brand new secret Invasion trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!